injustice twos fighter pack 3 includes
The Enchantress and thanks to the latest
live stream from developer NetherRealm
we got to see her in action to see the
rest of the roster be sure to check out
the rest of our injustice to character
breakdowns so let's talk about her back
one which is this magical blast it's a
low hitting move it's relatively fast
yeah it causes a pretty nice knockdown
the only way you're getting a combo off
it really for the most part is using
that medium run chorus which we'll cover
later but yeah you kind of just have to
commit to it it is safe but you you're
spending the bar on hit or miss she also
has this 4 to 3 watches a mid pretty
good range it's pretty fast and you can
actually meter burn it and then they're
trapping a giant block of ice all right
that's a meter burn due north it's a
meter burn normal attack there's a few
of those in the game and you can hit
confirm this which means like you can
see oh it hit and then you can go into
the meter burn and then even get a free
back three all right do a big combo yeah
it's kind of testing because you meter
burn before it hits like it changes the
beginning attack so that also makes it
so if you're punishing something that's
pretty punishable you can do 4 to 3
meter burn back 3 4 3 is all in class
rules so that's very nice I have
something we always talk about - a lot
of fighting game fans really like our
advancing moves oh yeah and that that's
it that is a good good good bit of an
advancement to it another one of her key
normals azar back - which actually uses
a magical energy sword right it's got
more range than her forward - so you use
it in those ranges where you maybe want
to try and lift punish something that
won't quite reach or you think the
person might walk back you don't want to
whip right
face right cetera that's also a hate
confirmable straying off right first it
is now when people thought they thought
that maybe enchanted to be his owner as
we're seeing with these moves she does
really try to control that middle grass
yeah you can see even her jump attacks
are gonna day this is her jump to and
it's really really good a lot of range
and I think one more move to look at
would be her two three combo which it
starts with this gut jab and then goes
into this diamond and the diamond has a
lot of uses you can actually just do it
immediately it's a combo or you can hold
it down and charge it and that's fully
charged it becomes an unblockable and
there's unique twist to it she also has
two one where she will hold it out and
if the opponent tries to attack it's an
auto parry that does a big chunk of
damage so that's just that's an
interesting mix up we have except a lot
of a care and she can dash out of it she
can cancel it so like if the opponent
hey I'm gonna be unblockable and they're
like oh I'm gonna punish that
unblockable you'll never get me this
time you witch
boom they get there now here's the thing
do the other one real quick do do both
not to him doing way poopsykins you can
actually tell the difference in the
diamond yes
so this diamond has no like lit up peaks
yeah or the other one does so if you're
playing a lot you can discern them it's
not super easy right but there is a
difference and look one of those things
where if you're looking for that it kind
of has to be held long enough for you to
notice which one it is and even then it
might be do the layers and layers of
mix-ups of doing in and dashing out of
it and all kind of good stuff
is there any other normal you wanted to
show you should show her duck that's
true because this looks cool her back
there he's one of my favorites in the
game and her for three to pull a strike
it does have different ranges yeah which
is different yes her for three she can
actually do close medium and far several
characters have a close to medium one
she's the only one that has a far one so
for for three can hit from pretty far
away and then she can romp and do it so
for me like players like me that's like
another special move essentially yeah
yeah yeah you're gonna use in ranges you
normally
would not use it for three but that's
kind of it let's also check out our
throat because it's definitely one of
the coolest in the game yeah I want to
say I just like how they came out a lot
that's really cool I remember I first
saw you I first saw it when it was
there's no like that these are like cool
effects to it yet yeah I was still like
that's gonna be amazing and it turned
out really well
and I do love the fact that every time
we do a stream we show the throw and we
say that's the coolest throw we've seen
here and that's actually a good point
yeah last time like Adam yeah that
destroyer was baller um and we're down
to is also a lot of people even notice
in the trailer heard down to is
fantastic it's super fast and it's super
high it's it's great so I think you can
understand that you'll notice she
doesn't have a lot of high-low mix-ups
she her big overhead is one two to the
second hit and her low like we said you
have to come in if you want to do a
combo but in the mid to long range she's
really really strong and I think that
complements our special moves so we'll
start with her astral solgryn where she
tears your own soul out and then crushes
it this is a good combo ender it's the
move she'll do like a down one into it
if she wants like a quick down one is to
wake up attack right it's a wake up
attack it's punishable but it has good
range it's one of those things were like
it's also gonna be hard to punish from
further away right like it's one of
those things were on paper it's super
punishable but if they're super far away
it's gonna be kind of hard and that's
really her only typical by-the-numbers
special move from here on out we're
gonna get weird that's a good shot
actually by the members okay so this is
one of a resource move she will actually
kill herself instead of it doing any
more damage she will take their salt
into her body and absorb their soul
energy into her health yep so it RA is
starting to get weird
yeah and now we're gonna get really
weird so he has Hell's Gate
and once the gate is active it will
actually reflect projectiles back as her
own energy beam and the cool thing is
she's full she is fully capable of
moving her down and playing the game
you can see it's very fast as a really
good recovery last for a long long time
and this move is gonna complement the
rest of her move set this is a move
that's gonna be great
she could put it out and now Superman
it's like oh man doing heat zap is
dangerous and she's gonna do her
character power and her other buffs
like for example her Kurt's which i
think is one of her four moves she draws
a pentagram and then she will actually
debuff the opponent the interesting
thing is this move does not actually hit
she does it and it's going to connect
and lust Superman is in an invincible
state like he's knocked down we're back
yeah if she's able to point he is cursed
never can you block it you know this
isn't yeah this is not an attack you can
block or duck or anything like that so
what do the curses actually do so
there's four different curses that can
happen that one for example prevents
super meter from being gained that one
if you meet or burn a move it damages
you and gives Enchantress meter one of
them disables special moves from being
used and the last one is you take damage
when you jump or duck so if you put that
on sonic Fox you probably gonna win the
game yeah like and you'll also notice it
does a little bit of damage at first
you're thinking oh it's like three that
was you accursed screwed up the wall to
sugar character power for show later and
she's gonna do a curse and then you try
to get in because you don't want to deal
with the curse and that's when she
starts hitting her or the long lash now
does the the curse stack you keep
refreshing the same one if you curse
someone and curse them before it so it
just reapplies the same curse so you
don't get a reroll or anything but it
still does that 3% or whatever damage so
for example if you get you know special
move disable curse you and your against
you know as owner you can keep doing
that and you're like hey you gotta come
to me yeah yeah you'll notice from
fullscreen she doesn't have that much of
a presence in cirno's like a projectile
or like teleporting like that
but you have to come to her
this is gonna add up yeah that's a
special so so real quick sighs want to
talk about cheque to chance for me to
talk about okay one person said finally
a true an ties owner the next one the
next thing underneath it is okay Oh as
owner yes I mean this is funny how that
yeah
yeah maybe against another male a
character you'll see here do stuff like
that but she tricks little boxes this
this curse if you if you do it you'll
see it takes quite a while to happen
here
well gonna be using it too much for but
how here's a trick to it when you meet
her permit she can actually leave it at
almost any point miss right actually
that's really interesting things to it
but and another example you're cursing
kind of far away I'm like oh I want to
stop her
yeah and then you get that's your main
combo starter and that's what the combo
star and kind of a trap move so it turns
into it turned into a wall balance which
I really love it's one of the few moves
in the game that's not a physical hit at
all and yet when you leader burn it it
becomes one of her best physical bits so
now let's talk about for mana shield
when this is active instead of taking
damage from a health bar if I am hit I
will actually take the damage through
her sue reader so check out our super
meter I think all right so now if I'm
hit you can see it's actually draining
of super meter this is an awesome really
interesting menacing move and that takes
no damage she will take no damage while
she has an active and wall she has super
meter to take so we're looking at a
tournament yes end of the game
enchantress is her life bar is flashing
and she has made the decision hey
instead of clashing or using my super
I'm gonna poured this meter she
activates it she could be hit it's not
like you gain armor but she will not
take the damage for a life bar and
that's gonna allow her to take more
risks to me more crazy and it's an
ultimate it's a huge lifesaver we have
had matches in the lab where it's like
why won't you die if she's just want
done because she had three to four bars
or two bars yeah well then again once
once that happens if she does get combo
and she's on the ground now she's
missing
two bars of a durable right and that
means she's not gonna be able to clash
you know work or yeah the club yet lose
yeah she would not be able to meet her
birth this you've been combos she
wouldn't be able to get her health back
with this I think she's like a lot of
characters injustice she's not an overly
strong character if she doesn't have
meters so it's it's you in injustice one
of the key things this meter makes you
really really good class saves your life
how do you weigh it she has this third
option which i think is really cool and
it's not just end of game that's just my
favorite way you can use it for a magic
pixel imagine an enchantress player in
tournament the magic pixel scenario is
already annoying
I was actually even been first runs
right to me that's actually sometimes in
this in the adjusted justice the way our
life bars work you want to get as much
damage out but like if you've drained
their life bar you don't want to lose
yours when he get as much damage out to
you go to second rounds yep absolutely
so moving on she has this parry move
when this is active she will actually
teleport behind them and then depending
on the recovery move she can actually
get a combo so this is one of the very
rare full combo parries that does excuse
me that doesn't use a bar meter and she
has a second option she'll actually jot
down from the ground and she can get a
full jump in so the Perry's not that
fast it's got to be one of the slower
ones right yeah yeah but you don't even
have to use a bar meter and if they do a
move with longer recovery they're gonna
get blown up so it's pretty effective
yeah it's also interesting too because
you know if you carry a down one for
example you're not gonna be able to
punish it because they recover so fast
but you're gonna appear from the ceiling
or behind them and they have to react to
that right it might be hard for them to
even just block which side you're gonna
end up on so let's go into her super
move before you talk about a character
power that's good
awesome man Superman got beat up by his
own soul he's weak to magic right that's
cannon Oh brilliant
which means an answer to Supergirl
finally right right enchanted
alright so her character power is super
interesting
she actually summons a demon the Lord
Sebulba
now Sebulba acts on his own I'm not
controlling him once i summon zubaba is
going to go forward and follow the
opponent and eventually he's gonna do
this big overhead the explosion also
acts as a hit so you can see it's to hit
so if he tries to armor it he's gonna
get blown up like literally blown up by
that Hellfire but so Allah has a few
commands of his own I can actually stop
them and now Superman tries to walk
forward you can see he's blocked so this
is absolutely awesome for hey I'm gonna
do my curses I'm gonna turn my man's
shield on I'm gonna get my wall out the
demon totally complements all the moves
we just talked about and the last one is
she could summon them it didn't blow up
my snapping her fingers and he blows up
so the ball is a ball but there's gonna
be oh this is if you're one of those
players that you like your weird corner
unblockable setups you can go nuts like
what are some of the ideas you came up
with yeah I mean there's situations
where you know you can Oh
standing to is about that yeah you can
go standing too and you know charging
the three walls of Allah isn't that
defenseless stance behind you
and you might let it rip and hit them if
they try and jump out what it's good
yeah you know or if you you know if they
just sit there and wait oh I'm scared
you hit him with the unblockable and
then do the attack and you get a combo
of it there's lots of crazy stuff I mean
I'm excited to see what people come up
with interesting ways to use the demon
yeah and like I said it totally
complements removalist she's she's one
of those characters where once she gets
going she can really steamroll you like
it's like a snowball rolling downhill
she's got the wall out she's got the
curse out then she gets managed to kneel
and she has two bars you're not even
leader the demon totally starts that
alright it's my time now so you wouldn't
you want to get on top of this real
quick you wouldn't be history like her
wake up's fine for what yeah her wake up
sit so I'm in it gets the job done right
so generally like get on top of it early
yeah win or she might start using all of
the when we talk we call them resources
the resources yes yeah absolutely no two
about the curse is if you have an
opponent curse and do certain moves they
get amplified and consume the curse like
her throw will do more damage than the
standard alone percent and give her half
a bar here's another example you can see
normally they fall out of this however
if you have the curse up when it breaks
they will not and you actually get a
reached and so there's another example
of setups you can find with that oh yeah
plenty of stuff yeah so let's go hard
the pages but absolutely and that's
that's how she rolls and you learn that
from Jun blowing chest piece thing and
her leggings and my favorite part a lot
of people wondered can you change her
magical effects with your shader yes you
can I love this orange color it changes
all of them super cool alright so in
this loadout this one changes her
character power she gets magical clones
of herself only one is real it's very
similar to a boob Zatanna hat so if you
really like satanís play style i think
you're gonna like her period but this is
even better like you can really make her
like [ __ ]
yeah that's one of the cool
opportunities of the abilities as you
can bring back some throwback moves that
you might have liked in other games
yeah and you can actually choose which
of the witches you're controlling whoa
when the opponent's gonna have to guess
which way I knew yeah yeah Russell
Burke's not like that also on this
loadout I gave her a meter remain a
shield where when she is in this bubble
she takes significantly reduce damage
but the main reason I wanted to show us
because the effects are awesome I that
when we look moving over this yesterday
I didn't see the mirroring that was
happening with yeah with the Epirus
that's awesome
yeah so she takes less damage inside
under the dome yeah under the dome
significantly less damage so you're
winning in the mid range but you'd like
it even better boost you know this is a
match where she's only gonna win range
you put that up you get to play your
game and take less damage when you turn
out to be wrong very very strong so move
for somebody like me I shouldn't use it
because I don't ever I'm never wrong
well I was I thought you're about to say
you're never winning in the midriff
don't don't
I about want you to talk more but not in
situations where it's against me all
right so one more load out yeah all
right I really like this one too I
really like the shader I like how this
one looks oh hi oh yeah yeah the
electrum I think it looks great
the pants the cool arm gear and here I
actually replaced her demons gate with a
projectile she gets his energy wave it
does not last fullscreen you can see
it's very slow allows you to follow it
and the meter burn it's super cool she
will actually do another wave and then
it becomes bigger and again it travels
if she can go behind so she can do stuff
like that and then use that to bite on
some of the ball bah all kind of fun oh
yeah I love it can you go back
fullscreen just the animation oh this is
really cool because he goes across and
then the next one is over yeah so then
it's like it's a cross pattern so
there's things a nice attention to
detail we were saying before that she's
not really a traditional zoner if that's
what you want
if you
for example doctor from Ohio that's been
desperately looking for a news owner you
could equip this move and here you go
you can play player matches and use this
and zone to your heart's content
really personalizing Street awesome
cuckoo those are great I think we should
probably get into some matches we some
matches play some place of money back
yeah some games some games